all right so Pocahontas was sort of the
beginning of the downfall of people's
interests and Disney animated movies
hunchback didn't exactly help Hercules
killed it this is one of the
most confusing
oddly put together yeah I don't even
want to say Disney films it just fills
in general the choices they make to tell
this story or stories is just so
mind-boggling nothing about it makes
sense it's sort of like the mad lives of
Disney films the musical accompaniment
to be gospel okay the designer of the
movie is gonna be scarf a the guy who
did the wall okay the look and tone of
the movie is going to be Las Vegas I
didn't what and the singer of the main
song is going to be Michael Ball oh you
are dead to me movie yeah I don't know
what the mindset was maybe they just
wanted to try something so different to
sort of get him out of a ditch but man
does it backfire okay well let's talk
about the story it's Greek mythology you
got all the gods up on Mount Olympus and
Zeus is happy because of the birth of
his son Hercules but Lord Hades the
ruler of the underworld what's to see
his son get destroyed because he's
apparently gonna stop him from taking
over everything in the future so he
gives him a potion that takes away his
godly powers it's interesting
hey much like Superman Hercules has
raised among people but again just like
Superman he finds out that his father is
a God among men that he himself has
supernatural powers and just like
Superman he goes to save the day
wherever he can with his incredible
strength and just like Superman you
seeing a pattern here he falls in love
with a snarky woman who constantly has
to be saved but once Hades finds out
that Hercules is alive he tries to use
the woman named Megara to seduce him and
take away his powers Hades uses her as
bait to try and get him to lure his
powers away and that's exactly what he
does
leaving Hades to take over the land and
Hercules to try and stop him however he
can I guess in many respects the
comparisons to superhero shouldn't shock
me I mean it is sort of where the origin
of superheroes came from
Greek mythology but like I said it's the
choices they make in the way they tell
this story that just really makes it God
Hercules is not very interesting we've
seen this idiot before he's not very
bright but he's got a good heart he'll
fall for whatever stupid plan you put in
front of him but God she's just so
wide-eyed he can't help but feel sorry
for him
Megara is sassy but that's about it
there's not really much tour after that
yeah they tried to give her a pass but
she's still not that interesting she's
just a few one-liners and a sneer and
speaking of which that's exactly what
the teacher is to Danny DeVito plays
Danny DeVito
yeah he's the trainer he's Mickey from
the Rocky movies and again there's
nothing new to it except for the fact
that's in Greek mythology but why would
we want to see that the only thing
that's kind of entertaining is James
Woods as Hades because well again it's
one of the weird odd choices that I
guess or works to its advantage I mean
how strange that this guy doesn't talk
like a traditional villain he talks much
more like a lawyer agent so I would be
eternally grateful if you would just
take a day off we dance because we
schmooze we carry on we go home happy
what do you say come on he's funny but
he's not enough to save the movie and
all the other side characters are just
totally forgettable I loved Scarface
work but here it's really not used well
in something like the wall it really
shines because his work is so different
and strange in a movie about Greek
mythology maybe it could work but not
the way they're telling it this isn't
Greek mythology this is the Excalibur
Casino tells you the story of Greek
mythology the songs I don't remember a
one I barely even remember parts where
they did sit so what were they thinking
when they put this together the only
thing I can contemplate is that maybe
they were trying to go for something
similar to what they did with a ladder I
mean like I said before Aladdin was sort
of Arabia meets Vegas but that worked
because the colors were so good the
designs were so good and there was still
chemistry between the two main
characters it's sort of new who was
trying to please and it had enough of a
broad scope to reach a general audience
this does not not to say that doesn't
have its fans and sure it dogs but I
don't know when you look at statues and
sculptures of Hercules and then you
think Disney Animation bringing back to
life this isn't what I think
which is fine if it was better or an
entertaining alternative but it's really
not it's clumsy it's flawed the story is
so recycled the characters are so
recycled and not just from other Disney
film but other tire cliches as well this
is definitely one of my least favorites
maybe if it wanted to go full force into
straight-up satire of the Hercules
stories which I'm not saying would
necessarily work but that's the only way
I can see these choices making sense but
when you still have to have a villain
who's intimidating a hero who's likable
on romance you're supposed to believe
and well actual suspense in the climax
you can't do this here and expect people
to be that invested like I said I hear
it's growing a bit of a fanbase but I
probably won't be a month it's just a
little too weird and clumsy